[Music]
reality-tv can go light on the reality
sometimes and presenting events as
authentic and unaltered while secretly
scripting and staging important scenes
is common here are a few events that
survivalists bear grylls didn't really
have to survive but it sure made for a
better story on screen the Sierra Nevada
mountain region is home to some of the
last truly wild horses in the United
States and wild mustangs have lived in
this area for centuries in a season one
episode of man vs. wild grills was shown
attempting to lasso some of the steeds
but it turned out that these Mustangs
might not have been so wild after all
the crew reportedly hired them from a
trekking station near their filming
location these were actually relatively
tame animals that were accustomed to
being around humans according to a
Sunday Times of London reports of course
that doesn't play as well to audiences
what makes for a more interesting scene
showing grills trying to sling a lasso
around a wild mustang poor admitting
that the crew essentially rented a few
horses that weren't actually running
wild the answer is obvious everyone
knows that an active volcano poses a
threat because of all the lava and there
are other dangers that can be present
like toxic gas in an episode of man vs.
wild in which Grylls explores the Mount
Kilauea volcano in Hawaii he's shown
working to avoid patches of molten lava
and clouds of so-called killer gas but a
safety adviser for the show told The
Sunday Times that while the gas should
be avoided in large quantities the drama
on the show was heightened using
off-camera smoke machines as for the
lava itself the crew used burning coals
to make the scene look more dangerous an
active volcano is scary enough they
probably didn't have to add all that in
man vs. wild grills is supposed to be on
his own in whatever inhospitable
environment he ended up in after all
it's called man vs. wild not grills and
his crew lending a helping hand vs. wild
but it's been revealed that grills has
been assisted by his crew on several
occasions without letting the audience
in on the truth even when he was not in
immediate danger
get inside both IVC guns after serving
as a consultant on the show survival
expert mark why nerds told the times if
you really believe everything happens
the way it's shown on TV you are being a
little bit naive for instance in one
episode that Weinert worked on grills
supposedly built a raft using only
natural materials that he found around
him like hibiscus twine palm leaves and
bamboo
however Weinert said that he personally
worked with a team of builders to put
the raft together and it was taken apart
so grills could be filmed putting it
together on camera in addition to mark
Winer its grills and his crew often
brought on other survival experts as
consultants on man vs. wild
there was nothing shady about that in
particular as long as they weren't doing
grills it's work for him but on at least
one occasion a consultant later revealed
that this was exactly what was going on
Nick rumens worked with grills on an
episode of man vs. wild in Western
Australia Grumman's told the herald-sun
that while he enjoyed his experience
working on the show and thought that
grills was a good person overall viewers
should know that the show was
predominantly scripted Grumman's also
explained that he was often responsible
for building grills as shelters and
finding him animals to eat in this
episode it was snakes admitting he was
disappointed by the final cut of the
episode rumens added whatever he does
isn't survival but it's definitely
entertaining Les Stroud is the host of
the show survivor Man which had a
similar premise to man vs. wild
but Stroud insists that his show was a
much more realistic picture of what it's
like to survive in the wild and man vs.
wild was basically a sham Stroud is not
a big fan of grills and he made this
very clear in a reddit AMA in 2013 he
stated that many of the survival skills
that grills had taught on the show would
actually not be very helpful for example
Stroud singled out an episode in which
Grylls was shown squeezing drinking
water from elephant dung something
Stroud claims would be impossible unless
the crew specifically soaked it with
water beforehand that is a fun moral of
the story man vs. wild shouldn't be seen
as a realistic documentary style show
it's entertainment above anything else
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]